Rishi sunak on his way to prime
minister's questions preparing to defend
a u-turn on his attendance at the cop 27
U.N climate Summit in Egypt next week
just a few days ago he was apparently
too busy to go heavy criticism followed
now he's changed his mind there is no
long-term Prosperity without action on
climate change and there is no energy
security without investment in
Renewables that's why I will attend cop
27 next week to deliver to deliver Mr
Speaker on glasgow's Legacy of building
a secure clean and sustainable future
this is Mr sunac as Chancellor at that
Glasgow cop 26 Summit last year showing
that he does understand the power of
presence
but perhaps his decision was also
hastened by former prime minister Boris
Johnson who told Sky News last night
that he would be going to Egypt I was
invited but I was invited by by the
Egyptian Stan very happy again whatever
the reason for sunax change of heart
opposition MPS are unimpressed the Prime
Minister has clearly been shamed into
going to cop 27 and the fact that he had
to be drag Kicking and Screaming to go
to this important Summit shows he just
doesn't get it the back and forth at
number 10 has already had an impact on
the UK's reputation as a leader on
tackling global warming but there will
be other consequences too the point of
the United Nations Summit is for
countries to overcome domestic political
issues and focus on climate change but
for many attending cop 27 in Egypt
what's going on in there has become an
unwelcome distraction at a time when
there is still a huge amount of work to
be done
the climate change driven disasters
unfolding over the last year Drive the
point home the world is off track and
things are getting worse I think it
sends an awful signal to all countries
because clearly if industrialized
nations like the UK like France like
Germany or the US do not achieve the
climate objectives if they do not
respect their climate commitments or can
we expect that other countries emerging
in developing countries could do so if
the new prime minister wants to have a
positive impact at the summit he has
ground to make up and quickly Hannah
Thomas Peter Sky News in Westminster